I forgot that you were married to Ryan
Reynolds
Scarlett Johansson makes a rare comment
about her ex Ryan Reynolds he's a good
guy yeah the actress offers up kind
words about her former husband while
chatting with Gwyneth Paltrow on the
goop podcast I forgot that you were
married to Ryan Reynolds
we were married we weren't married very
long but we were married when I first
met you at foreign yeah I was married we
love a good Ryan Reynolds in our house
he's a good guy the topic came up after
Gwyneth asked Scarlett if she's been
married two times
she corrected the goop owner saying
she's actually on her third after Ryan
Scarlett tied the knot with Roman do
react in 2014 before Calling it Quits in
2017. that's when she got together with
her now hubby SNL star Colin Jost yes
this is pretty cool
it's hard to have a lot of complaints
I'm very happy I feel very lucky on the
podcast Scarlett reflects on how her
previous marriages positively impacted
her current one I would never have
probably been ready for a relationship
like the one that I have with Colin at
different times in my life because I
wasn't comfortable setting my own
boundaries I didn't know what I wanted
but like what I needed from somebody
else the star opens up about how she
realized that there are certain things
that she needs in a partner I never
realized oh it's really important for me
I need to be with a compassionate person
that's like a fundamental
characteristic that has to be there and
I just I think that understanding what
those fundamental things are that you
need in a partner is
like a must I think for longevity anyway
there's going to be disagreements or ups
and downs or you're working you know on
different things at different times and
blah blah blah but I think identifying
those things was a game changer for me
and while it's easier said than done
stands by it you get wrapped up in oh
you know things that are shiny and
attractive in somebody whatever that
could be they're sexy or passionate or
you know in different kinds of ways that
are really appealing it's not like the
sexiest thing to do to examine those
fundamental characteristics that you
know that are a necessity for you but I
think you know that's why it worked with
Colin and I at that time was that I was
finally able to step back and actually
respect myself enough to know what those
things were and be okay with it
[Music]